last dance has gotten a ton of attention
the documentary on Michael Jordan what
was your general takeaways from from
watching it um you really get a glimpse
into the mind of you know who Michael
Jordan was and what made him so great
you get to see kind of how the Bulls are
almost kind of like the Beatles in a
sense because of the league but that's
something that obviously I never really
got to experience because I was too
young you know when they're really on
their run I was four or five years old
so you understand who Michael Jordan is
how great he was as a player in all that
stuff but you all remember all the
fanfare necessarily surrounding it
Dennis Rodman might be my favorite
player of all time now but yeah just
overall it was it was it was interesting
to see I mean really I wish they could
have dived or doe even deeper into
everything that went on but obviously
you know you only have so much time and
in a ten-part dark yeah I saw a tweet
about Rodman somebody said like the
first week was if you want to know how
good Dennis Rodman was he had Michael
Jordan chasing around Vegas to get him
to come to practice was you telling me
this man was you know a multi time NBA
champion he basically was doing drugs
drinking going to WWE matches like they
laid out everything in the documentary
and he still was you know not even the
best guy on his team right and by the
way like all that happens because
there's no social media imagine
something like today there's no way
there's no way you would get e visser
ated by you know coaching stuff fans
media all that like there'd be no way
because somebody pull out the camera
phone and you know video evidence is a
lot different than hearsay yeah that's
not impossible no I'm just a match like
I was watching it and when the when he
disappears after one of the games right
and they find out he think I was sitting
there saying like imagine today of a
player just disappeared right everyone's
like where is he you have fans going
nuts all over social media gonna be a
old global manhunt to find the player oh
yeah well I mean he'd be found because
he'd be walking through an airport
whether it was private or not it's the
way it was type of picture and be like
hey I'm
you know Cleveland Ohio and I just saw
Dennis Rodman and everybody be like what
the heck is he doing at Cleveland Ohio
so yeah it would it would be over quick
yeah and then what's your take on I saw
like horse grant
I think Scottie Pippen a couple of guys
were unhappy with how the way the
documentary was put together like what's
kind of your takeaway from that I mean I
think the Scottie Pippen one actually
kind of caught me off guard because if
you look at the way Michael Jordan
talked about him he basically said like
I don't win without you you know and for
somebody that is notorious for being
extremely hard and unforgiving and
holding grudges and racially competitive
for him to basically say like hey I
needed Scottie you know I didn't want
him on you I needed him on the team
that's a huge compliment and then you
know the other stuff that went down I
mean a lot I was Scotty's decision so
you know I I don't really have too much
to say on the Scottie front on the
Horace Grant front I can see how that
was tough you know they they blamed him
for snitching effectively but you know
one of things he said was that for the
guy to published the story he needed to
people at minimum to corroborate the
story so he said you know forget the
fact that one I'm denying I ever said
anything but two if he needed to people
it couldn't have only been Matt says
that like it couldn't have only been me
so like how are you guys solely pinning
this on me there's got to be somebody
else so I could definitely see what
Horace Grant you know felt a certain way
the Scott the Scottie thing is you know
maybe it's personal or something I don't
know like I'm not I don't know those
guys but I can't really I can't begin to
comment on that yeah my two favorite
parts of the entire thing is one the
Steve Kerr story where they get into
like the fistfight over and it just
showed like one I think Kerr
understanding like hey if you stand up
and basically back it up
Jordan will respect you and I think
that's kind of like he just saw him over
and over and then to is the security
guard with the jheri-curl man and like I
guess part of as you're watching like
how much of the behind-the-scenes stuff
right so literally we see Jordan like
throwing
orders with security guards before the
game I'm assuming that a lot of that is
they pull the best parts right you know
and put into a documentary but like is
that that general atmosphere before the
games for players in the locker room or
did you feel like that was like oh that
must have been fun in the 90s because
we're not doing any of that type of
stuff now well not necessary for ters
and as of now people don't really have
their own personal locker rooms away
from the locker room but in terms of the
banter and the joking and you know that
type of stuff yeah that's that's that's
definitely consistently made Loughran
you got to remember like these are 15
highly competitive guys who are about to
you know kind of go to war in a sense
you know you don't want to be on all the
time you want to be on you know an hour
two hours before the game up until the
game ends but when the game does in
especially after wins you want to kind
of be able to turn off and you know so
in those moments you're definitely going
to see more quarter type of atmosphere
and guys laughing and joking with each
other